hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our
Morpheus saga and we left it off after
morphe defeated johann jakob Leventhal a
Hungarian master with a result of either
three to zero or two and a half to half
we we don't know but here is a game from
1854 now from 1850 to 1854 morphe did
not play a single chess game or well not
a single game that was recorded as he
was going to school and he didn't really
he didn't really want to play chess he
didn't study it he didn't try to become
better at chess or or anything like that
and here he faces his closest friend and
his school classmate Cheryl I'm dead -
Maury on or something like that as he's
a French descent not really sure how to
bronze that and it's a very interesting
one day Charla asked Morphy how is it
that doing the intelligent beings move
little pieces around the board and
called that recreation or something and
that then more if he told him well if
you knew how to play chess maybe you
would understand and then at some point
they were at together in the infirmary
and then Mario asked Morphy if he would
teach him how to play chess and Murphy
said ok and and he thought told him how
to play chess as they were they were in
the infirmary for a few days now we're
gonna get back to that but I know where
one what you're wondering where their
piece is missing here morph is missing a
rook and the night
well morphe always gave more young odds
even when Morgan became a stronger
player he still gave him at least a
night odds even though there it wasn't
necessary as he really became a lot
stronger but more if he still felt that
he should give him at least Knight odds
now we left it off at 1850 now if you
checked the database there are no games
in 1851 1850 to 1853 and even in 1854
there aren't all the mini games only
some friendly games between his uncle
Ernest Ernest Murphy and his classmate
Gugu Rochelle amoled do Maury on now as
we mentioned in 1850 Murphy enrolled
into Spring Hill College in Mobile
you know Alabama after finishing
Jefferson Academy and he did really well
he excelled in Latin in Greek and French
in English in mathematics he really
enjoyed philosophy and he got his
bachelors bachelors degree in 1854 well
or at least something that would be
similar to today's and bachelor's degree
and in 1855 a year later he got his
master's degree and later he enrolled
into into law school and two years later
in 1857 he finished law school but he
was he was too young to practice law so
he had to do something had to wait for a
whole year and then of course he decided
to play some chess so this is one of the
games between here's the bachelors
bachelor's degree and master's degree in
1854 I played against his well a
schoolmate and here he's just giving him
to pieces odds but it's quite quite an
exciting game even though these are
quite the odds so now without further
ado let's let's check it out so morphe
opens with E 4 and we have e 6 we're not
gonna call it the French defense since
he's missing well some pieces we have f4
and an out d5 Morgan goes for the center
right away as he should with E 5 by
Murphy as morphus already done material
he should really avoid trading anything
he just needs to make the position as
complicated as possible so nice the e7
and now comes the knight to f3
we have Knight eat the c6 and now g4 by
morphe we have Bishop to e7 in the now
d4 so quite quite a nice expansion here
with castles in the now c3 just
strengthening the center and here we
have f5 if Bishop to H for more FLE was
probably considering some like King G -
maybe even put the King on d3 just you
know try and force his friends to find
ways how to how to play the game even
though it's not all that complicated if
he really understood the chess you know
that he just well needs to trade down
although that's easier said than done as
you'll see in this game so f5 and more
if he goes he captures on f6 Ambus on
with the show characters on f6 enter now
H
or preparing to push even further with
the g5 and now Knight to a5 freeing the
the c6 square for for this night so as
you can see black is having some
problems developing his pieces we have
g5 attacking the bishop Bishop to e7 and
now even h5 more if he wants the push h6
o and open up the position now we have
Knight to d7 now instead and Bishop to
d3 Morphy already attacking h7 here and
now nights the b6 so not the greatest
way to develop your pieces when all the
action is on the King side but you know
you live you learn
we have Queen to c2 now more if he puts
that's a b2 Queen to c2 more if he puts
pressure on the h7 pawn and now you
could pretty much do anything here
you're still up material so ideas like
Bishop to d6 are good just going after
the f4 pawn also you might consider rook
to f5 you could give up some material
you don't really care your Europe a rook
and the night but here Morgan goes for
h6 and the morphe just says okay thank
you G cappers on h6 we have G captures
and now this position just shows how how
careless more if you played this game
and he didn't really I think too much of
his good friend Maury on because here
Quinta h2ax Queen to g2 check is winning
on the spot pretty much because if king
f7 its mate and after after this Queen
to G to check if you move the King King
h8 now Queen g6 you threaten mate rook
the rook has the block now looked at
five the only way to prevent this but
now Queen captures an H sex with check
King g8 and now rook the g1 with check
King of seven now Queen g6 check and
after this you're just getting made it
so this game just well shows that morphe
was probably even just teaching teaching
charles or or shawl I don't know if his
name is still pronounced ranger or maybe
it's just Charles from Orion or who
knows but yeah Murphy didn't want to end
it right away so he played rock to g1
with King to h8 or and now rook to g6
just going for that
h6 pawn and here rook to f6 mori own
defense properly
now we have Queen to g2 and now comes
Queen to f8 here you have to be careful
here morph is threatening rogue g7
followed by rook to h7 mate the bishop
still covers the h7 square so Queen to
f8 not allowing rook to come to g7 and
not Knight h4 if the rook is ever
captured you can always recapture with
the night when when the Queen could be
could be nice so Queen to f7 getting the
Queen away from such a nasty square and
now more if we just continues marching
forward f5 and here he really puts a
nice task in front of memorial will you
really calculate this properly or not so
here's what happens if you if you really
go into this ECAP choice on f5 now comes
for example Bishop captures an f5 there
are so many lines because black is still
up material you can pretty much do
anything but let's say Bishop captures
Knight characters and rook captures now
this this wouldn't be okay because of
for example rook captures an h6 and here
you have to part with the Queen Queen h7
captures captures and now Queen g6 check
even wins the rook so here it would be
white who's better so Cheryl decides not
to capture the pond as a lot of things
can go wrong as you've just seen so he
continues developing he wants to bring
this rook into the game and okay
still still winning for black not a
problem we have Bishop captures and h6
by Murphy and now rook to G if not
allowing the Bishop g7 or rook to g7 and
here Bishop to g5 again so what do you
play here there are again a lot of
things you could play for example a root
G capture some g6 can be played but then
you get F captors and g6 and this is now
actually winning for white because if
you move the Queen and well you kind of
have to move the Queen for example Queen
to f8 you get h6 and this just well now
win so of course you cannot even capture
because captures and you lose the Queen
so not not gonna happen on the other
hand you could try rook g7 which which
is possible but then you get Bishop
captures on f6 and if Queen captures
then you get rook captures on g7 now
Queen captures and g7 and my g6 check
again with very complicated play for
example King h7 now F captures an e6
opening
a discovery from this bishop we will not
a discovery but a preparation for a
discovery and after Bishop captures an
e6 now you cannot capture the bishop
here with the discovered chair because
after king h6 you don't really have a
good way of continuing the attack so
after Queen d2 check black and always
block Queen to g5 so that's not really a
problem
so after this Bishop captures an e6 you
cannot capture you'd have to go for
something like Knights the f4 check but
then at least after the the King moves
you will get something like characters
captures and you will grab this with
check King h6 now we're going to capture
here and after captures you're down a
piece but you're up to pawn you wrap up
on but for example Czech Bishop f3 you
can pick up this pawn so it will be 2
points for a piece black is of course
still better but Mario is nowhere
nowhere near and near as skillful that
you know tackle more fee even if he
reached the same end game so instead we
have rook F characters and g6 by Shara
and now comes Knight captures and g6
with check so what do you do here we
have rook captures on g6 but ignoring
this isn't better for example if King h7
then f6 just wins you open up this
diagonal and now pretty much everything
wins there are ideas like 95 when it
wins the Queen and if you try King g7
it's still the same thing f6 now comes
with check and after after some trades
here Bishop captures now h6 is deadly so
morphe has everything under control here
if King h7 now you have 95 check now the
queen is under attack so you might as
well give it up Knight captures real
characters and now even better captures
and f6 opens up an attack here the rook
is pinned you cannot capture the Queen
due to the bishop so not much you can do
here so instead mori on the plate rook
captures an g6 but now H characters and
g6
we have Queen to g7 and here Queen to h1
by morphine we have King to g8 of
getting out of check and now f6 and it
was in this position and moved 25 that
Cheryl emitted the Mauryan resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here which is quite quite
impressive as it really it's not
easy to calculate why this is this is
game over especially if you're not not a
really skilled player like our good
friend Charlie R but feel free to pause
the video for example if Bishop captures
an f6 how does white win here try and
figure it out while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on not
playing Bishop captures an f6
well because this just leads to nowhere
after Queen h7 checking f8 you don't
have a continuation no way to continue
this attack so congratulations to those
of you who found it and also to those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
after Bishop captures an f6 Queen to h3
after Bishop captures an f6 not that but
rather Queen to h7 check this is this is
winning now and now you have to capture
for example if captures then you just
deliver check and if you block this is
mate now a double Bishop mate if you
will quite quite the beauty also after
Queen to h7 check you could capture and
then after captures to go somewhere else
but it still doesn't matter Bishop
captures with to check the pawn is
guarded you have to either move the King
or capture the bishop then you get a
queen and again it's the game over so
lastly but not leastly you could move
the Queen and move the King let's say
King f8 but this also doesn't help you
because of Bishop h6 just winning the
Queen and whatever you play a white even
has Queen h8 check now the Queen is
pinned you cannot capture anything due
to the bishop so you have to move and
then you give up even more material
character scalpers captures with
checking these six and now well check
and now you get another queen of course
game over
so really a game against all odds were
more if he definitely had a lot of fun
and he could have finished a much sooner
but he he was just creating and creating
and creating and in the end you know
basically we even forgot that more if we
started this game without a rook and the
night so that's that's how good morphe
was and well he just wanted to teach a
girl or shot some some get some chess
and it's a interesting to point out this
game was played in 1854 but already in
1858
Morgan won the New Orleans Chess Club
Championship Morphy did not play of
course but still quote quite an
achievement so that's the game and it's
well like I said a very interesting to
point out that morphe finished law
school in 1857 he he still had to wait a
whole year before he starts a practicing
law and even prior to that in 1856 his
uncle Ernest Murphy he started sending
challenges to all the strongest players
in in America if they wanted to play
against Murphy as he was sort of
Morpheus biggest fan but no one ever
accepted the challenge even said that
there will be three hundred dollars to
the winner if you bid more for you know
you get three hundred dollars which in
those days was not a bad deal and if
Morphy beats you you still get one
hundred dollars out of those three
hundred four you know just for showing
up so it really wasn't a bad deal but
still no one accepted a challenge
because I guess people heard about
Murphy crushing Leventhal and they
didn't want to lose to lose to a little
kid well okay he wasn't a little kid
here he was already in 1854 at this time
he was about seventeen so but still you
know people people didn't want to play
and so he's his uncle and some very you
know prosperous people the started
talking about this Congress maybe they
should organize some sort of a chess
event maybe a chess Congress or or maybe
the first American chess congress if you
will but we're gonna get back to that in
the next video and we're going to talk
about how how Murphy visited how Murphy
almost didn't go and why he went and so
on but we have to leave something for
the next video as well so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it
our good friend Charl definitely didn't
but in the end he did learn something so
he he probably even did as like I said
he did he did win the New Orleans just
got championship four years after this
game yeah I would like to thank Thomas
Colin Christopher Decker's for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Paul
Morphy saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day